- Hello, Sal here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our Homeroom live stream,
I have a very exciting guest today.
But before we jump into that conversation,
I will give my standard
reminders to folks, one,
just reminder that we are a
not-for-profit organization,
the work that Khan Academy
does is only possible
because of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation.
You can go to khanacademy.org/donate.
Also wanna make a special shout out
to several organizations
that when they realized
that we were already running
at a deficit pre-COVID,
and in order to support, frankly the world
through the school closures,
we were running an even a larger deficit.
Special thanks to Bank of
America, Google.org, AT&T,
Fastly, and Novartis,
and the Amgen Foundation
for stepping up and
helping us close that gap.
Although we are still running a gap,
so any support at any
level for Khan Academy,
if you're in a position to do so,
it allows for a lot of other folks
who aren't in the position to do
to continue to keep learning,
especially as we're going through
these very, very hard times.
So with that, I'm super
excited to introduce our guest,
Maria Elena Salinas.
For many of y'all, she
is probably an icon,
someone that you grew up
with, for some of y'all,
she might be a relatively new name,
but for those of y'all say that
she is an icon for many poor folks.
She anchored Univision for many decades,
she's a contributor to CBS News,
really one of the iconic
journalists in the world.
Maria, thanks so much for joining us.
- Thank you so much Sal for
that very kind introduction
and (speaking in foreign
language) that's hello
to those of us who are
listening in Spanish
or watching in Spanish.
- Yeah, and thanks for that.
'Cause today we do have
our Spanish speaking.
There's a fully Spanish
version of Khan Academy,
es.khanacademy.org and
we're also posting this
on our Spanish language sites,
so yes, excited to have it-
- I notice there khan co
(speaking in foreign language),
that's really good.
Let's continue learning.
- Exactly,
- I can see it on the screen.
- So there's two things I
really wanna talk about today.
Obviously we're having this conversation
in very suboptimal times,
we're going through a pandemic
the pandemic has health impact,
it has an economic impact,
it's having an education impact,
and it does look like it's
disproportionately affecting
the Latinx community,
especially in the United States.
I definitely wanna talk about that,
and I also wanna make sure
we have time to talk about
your journey, which I find very inspiring
and I think a lot of young people watching
will find inspiring as
well, but let's start,
I guess maybe on the world
that we're in right now,
you recently did a
documentary on the pandemic
and how it's affecting the
Latinx community in particular.
What were the big headlines from that?
What were your big takeaways?
What did you learn from that?
- Well, for one thing,
I'm very happy that CBS
decided to do this special
lot of thing, it was enough to do just to,
one, two minutes, three minutes
stories in their newscasts
in their regularly scheduled programs,
but it was important and
it was important also
that we had a full Latino staff
all the reporters, producers,
researchers, bookers,
were all Latino, because
there's a relativity
that we have to the subject
and to the community.
We know our community
better than anyone else.
And I think the big
headlines out of that really
is that you said it, we
are disproportionately
being affected by this pandemic.
Latinos are getting
sick in higher numbers,
Latinos are dying in higher numbers,
Latinos are losing their
jobs in higher numbers
or making less money.
They are the essential workers
that keep the economy going
and while they do have a job
they're risking their lives,
and many of them don't
qualify for unemployment.
They don't qualify for a stimulus cheque.
So they're being affected
I think in economically
and also health wise, they're
being very, very effected
and it's not getting better,
it's getting worse, unfortunately.
- And what do you think
are the main levers
that are causing this inequity?
And then what do you think can be done
to at least lessen hopefully
eliminate some of these issues?
- Well, it's the historical inequities
that have been really
exacerbated by the pandemic
poverty, unemployment,
insufficient savings.
I think there was one study that said
that more than half of
Latinos had only $500 or less
in their savings, lack of
access to adequate healthcare,
all these traditional inequities
or historical inequities,
they just got worse during this time.
And when it comes to education,
a subject that I know that
you're passionate about,
and that has to become your
mission and your passion,
Latino kids were staying
behind more than others,
more than any others.
And that is because only one
in three Latino households
has access to internet
and only half of them,
about 50% have enough computers at home,
not saying they don't have computers,
they don't have enough computers.
The majority of essential
workers do the types of jobs
that you can't do at home
from the comfort of your home,
in a Zoom Box, so they
do have go out and work,
but the ones that do have
to rely on the computer
and if they have two or three
kids, they don't have enough.
And even though school
districts across the country
have been distributing computers, laptops,
or tablets to kids around the country,
it hasn't been enough.
This morning, there was an
article in the Los Angeles Times
that talk precisely
about that point and said
that in California alone,
kids need more than 1 million computers
to be able to go back to
school and study from home.
- Now this last point,
obviously, as you know,
this has been something
that we've at Khan Academy,
we've been very focused on
throughout the pandemic,
even pre-pandemic around
the digital divide.
There's the education issue,
there's the economic issue,
and then there's the healthcare issue.
And maybe we'll start
with the education issue
just where you left off,
what do you think we can do?
Because I'm seeing the same thing,
when we talk to district
officials, we talked to educators,
even where there have been heroic efforts
to get a lot of laptops out there.
They're still losing a lot of kids,
and these kids are
disproportionately students of color.
A lot of their parents, as you mentioned,
they might be essential workers.
They're the folks that are making sure
that we can get our groceries,
they're the folks that are making sure
that other things are up and running.
And so these kids are less supported,
but personally I've been
at a loss of knowing
what the solution is, what can we do?
Obviously on our level, we're
trying as much as possible,
Hey, Khan Academy is there,
if you have internet access,
if you have a device,
even a cell phone use us,
that's something, but what else can we do?
Should we think about as a society.
- Well, you're right.
Latina parents are very concerned.
In fact, a recent survey
by Latino decisions
that focuses only on Latino
voters or Latino families
says that 53% are really
thinking of not sending
their kids back to school.
Now, a great majority say
that they wish they
could go back to school,
but that the only way that
they would send them back,
is if there were precautions
such as making sure that
the classroom is clean
and in such as making sure
that they're wearing masks
and taking the necessary
precautions there,
and 83% are concerned that their kids
will be left behind in their studies.
And that is a real concern.
But you know, when you think about kids
and going back to school and wearing masks
and taking all the necessary precautions,
I mean, I see it all the time.
I have two daughters and
I have two stepdaughters.
My two stepdaughters are both teachers.
One of them teaches second grade
and the other one teaches
at the university level.
The one that teaches
second grade tells me,
you sit in a class and not to have kids
on top of each other, hitting each other,
teasing each other, or having them wear
to make sure that the
mask is over their nose,
it's virtually impossible to do.
Now, she is only 32 years old.
She might not be at very high risk,
but her husband has diabetes.
He has childhood diabetes.
If she gets sick and takes
that home, her husband can die.
So these are the things
that we need to think about.
And my other stepdaughter who teaches
at the university level, she
teaches journalism at UCF,
same thing, they are doing virtual classes
and she'll be going in
to teach once a week.
However, she has a seven year
old son who's in second grade
and he's doing virtual classes says
she will not let him go to school
because she's very afraid
that he would get sick
because she has a little baby.
So every family has their story.
Every family has a set of circumstances
that makes them more vulnerable.
What the solution would be, of course,
for everyone to have access
to the necessary technology
so that they can study from home
so that the kids can
continue learning from home.
And maybe some of those school districts
who don't have cases
that are that serious,
maybe begin going back little by little
with taking all of these precautions,
but it really is scary how this has turned
into a political issue.
This isn't a matter of red and blue.
This is a matter of life and death.
So it's really sad and it's dangerous also
for this to happen.
I live in Miami and in Florida,
the governor is forcing
schools to go back in person
to have in person classes
otherwise he threatens with
withholding state funds.
Now, when the President said
he would withhold federal funds,
while you think it's only maybe
five, 10% of their budget,
but the state funds are a little bit more.
So it would be detrimental
to school districts.
- Yeah, I think there's several
things you're touching on
there, one is a school opening issue,
and yesterday we had the head of the NEA,
the largest teachers union,
and last week we had the head of the NFD,
and this is one of those
situations where regardless of
sometimes these things in
education turned very political,
but this is just a basic
health and safety issue.
And any epidemiologists that
you talk to will tell you
if there's a high incidence
in a community right now
to put kids, put 30 kids in a
not so well ventilated place
and a teacher who may or may
not be at high risk themselves,
but they're gonna have family members
that could be at high risk.
It's actually just not
even good for those people
directly involved, it's
bad for the whole community
because a pandemic, you have to keep,
it's gonna hurt all of us who
aren't even going to school
because it'll just create
more spread in the community.
What, I've seen some good examples,
actually the head of the
NEA yesterday talked about
Maryland doing a good job of
where even where kids don't,
they're going to distance learning,
which seems appropriate given
where we are in the pandemic.
But for those kids who need
those extra supports at home,
who might, maybe their
parent is an essential worker
and can't support kid while
they're during the school day,
they are opening the
schools up for a few of them
in a very careful way,
but they're still doing
distance learning from school,
but they're getting some kinda childcare
and they're getting some
support from some adults.
Are you seeing programs
that you think are helping,
I would say, especially
the Latinx community,
but just in general communities
that need extra supports right now,
or are you kind of discouraged by
the state of affairs right now?
- I do see a lot of help
and in lieu of having
our governments at all
levels help these kids.
You do see philanthropist
stepping up and helping
with different programs and
helping families with food,
helping families maybe pay their
rent and also in this case,
helping families distribute computers.
People are very kind and
they always tried to help.
We shouldn't underestimate the kindness
of the American people.
There was one case of a family
that I covered also for
CBS earlier this year,
just a couple of months ago
where these three little
boys, the Hernandez boys,
they had only two computers,
one that was provided by the school,
another one that they had at home,
and then the third boy
who was eight years old,
had to do his homework
on his father's phone.
And that created a problem only
because it's very difficult
for you to do homework on a phone.
Also not to mention the fact that
the data would be more
expensive for this family.
When the father is an unemployed
because he lost his job because of COVID
and the mother is a housewife,
she stays home taking care of the kids.
So when we aired this story,
I have so many tweets of people wanting,
stepping up and wanting to
help and wanting to donate
a computer to these kids and finally,
one person did get in
touch with the family
and did sent the little
boy an extra laptop.
But we have to rely on the
kindness of our neighbors
of organizations so that we can have this,
but let's say that we get
enough computers out there
that we'll get enough laptops
and that some philanthropist says,
okay, we need 1 million
in LA and in California,
we're gonna give them 1 million.
There's also the issue
of having access to WiFi.
In Texas for example, there was one area
where there was a school
bus that was retrofitted
to become a WiFi hotspot,
going to communities where
they knew that these families,
these low income families
didn't have access to it.
There were some families that told us
that they have to get in the car
and drive to the parking
lot of a McDonald's
or a Walmart or another store,
so that they're able
to use those hotspots.
That is a serious issue,
that's a serious problem.
And I don't know what the solution is.
I mean, is it money?
Is it always that we
throw money into things
and then they get solved, money does help,
but in this case it's gonna
be, it takes a lot more.
I interviewed a teacher of
these three Hernandez boys
that I mentioned to you and she told me
that her main concern
was not the fact that
they might stay behind she
says they're smart kids,
they're young enough where
they will eventually catch up.
She was worried about their security.
She was worried that if
they're not in school
that maybe they live in areas
that might be a little dangerous
and they go out on the streets
and put themselves in danger
or that because the parents go home,
the older kids have to take
care of their younger siblings.
Therefore don't have the
ability of spending enough time
and having enough attention to the classes
that are being given online.
- Yeah, it's a super tough situation.
We had Dr. Fauci on a couple
of couple of weeks ago,
and when we played out
how this all might work
and I've talked to other folks who are
very well steeped in the
epidemiology of the pandemic.
It looks like the best
case scenario is that
we're looking at a unusual
circumstance that we're in
maybe for another nine,
10, 12, the next year.
And there's even some probability
that goes beyond the next year.
If some of these early
vaccines don't work out.
And so given that, let's
just say we're looking at
a year of a health crisis,
a year of a lot of service industries
being really difficult,
restaurant, transportation, travel,
and a year of some form of
distance or hybrid learning.
where do you think this is gonna leave us
a year from now for having
the same conversation?
What do you think is
gonna happen to society?
And especially a lot of the populations,
a lot of the folks that
you've been working with
over the last many decades.
- I think they're gonna
be hurting very much.
People keep saying, we're
all in this together
and we're all in the same boat,
but we're not, it's the same storm,
but we're in different boats.
Some are in yachts,
others are in sailboats,
and others are in rickety, little boats
that can easily turn over.
And we have to take into consideration
that not everyone can survive this.
Not everyone can have
homeschooling or special tutors.
So it affects everyone,
we're talking mostly
about kids right now,
but when you talk about businesses
that will not be able to survive,
families that will not
be able to pay the rent.
Even though there was
a moratorium on rent,
there's so many families
that can become homeless,
if that moratorium doesn't
extend for several more months
or whatever is needed in
some States like California,
that has been extended by the
governor, but it can happen.
And you also have to
think of the landlords.
Well, they're paying that also,
there's some landlords that
might have multiple homes,
and there's some that I be depending only
on the rent of that person
in order to be able to
pay their own bills.
So it's a domino effect
that doesn't have to be,
and I think that's what's
the most frustrating thing
if everyone just cooperated and
everyone followed the rules,
this would be over so much faster.
We see the New Zealand,
was in the countries
that took action early on
and didn't open up too fast.
And also I think another
problem that we have here
in the United States is
that there's no uniformity.
It's not only that the federal
government doesn't have
any specific regulations or mandates
it's that they vary state by state,
and even within the state,
they vary county by county.
So what do you do?
I mean, how do you solve a problem
when it might be better
in the area where you live
and maybe your neighboring
area is much worse
or maybe better do you move there
and create another housing crisis?
I do see it as a major
problem and you're right,
it could go on a lot longer.
I know my daughters and I
who are working from home,
they're 23 and 25 and we've
realized that the rent,
we have to think that at
least the rest of this year,
this is the way it's gonna be.
Instead of worrying
every day and every week,
is this gonna be over?
Do we have, is it gonna be next week
or the week after the month after
just assume that the rest of the year,
this is the way that we're going to live.
But it could happen beyond that.
Like you say, it could very
well happen beyond that.
And we have to prepare for this.
I think it's gonna take a
catastrophe to shake us up
and say, okay, we've gotta do something.
Maybe it's gonna take a
complete shutdown of the country
in order for us, God
willing know mark some wood
knock on wood, let's
hope that doesn't happen,
but if it's necessary
then it should happen
because we can't go on like this.
It's just hurting everyone,
every single person is being hurt by this,
especially low income families.
- Absolutely right, and it's
definitely there's levers
that are out of your mind controls.
But as you imagine, the
federal and the state level
pandemic response, we have
patterns other countries
quicker testing, et cetera.
And then what are the economic safeguards,
which it does, you bring up a good point.
It's not just a moratorium
on evictions or rent,
the landlords, some of them
are also very vulnerable.
So you have to go through
the whole system all the way
through the banks and the financing system
and whatever else.
I'm getting a ton of questions
here on social media.
This first one from Chris
Young from Facebook.
He's a high school teacher new to ESL,
new to English as second language,
he's asking what are my must do's
to be better at including
my Hispanic community.
- Well, yeah, I'm glad
that you brought that up
because some of the most
vulnerable are also kids
that are taking ESL classes
and kids that have special needs.
How do you get to them?
I mean, without that personal contact,
what do you tell this teacher?
The most important thing
is, even if they have to be,
if there's to be less hours of learning,
there needs to be consistency.
The kids need to feel that
it's something important.
They need to feel that they're
doing something important
and that it's making a difference.
So I think that consistency
is gonna help them understand
not to get discouraged.
It might take a lot
longer for them to learn,
but it's better to take longer
than for them not to be learning at all.
So whatever ESL teachers can do,
make an extra effort because
they have extra needs
to teach these kids online
and to keep them engaged
and make them interested in understanding
that it's important for them
to do this every single day.
Even if it's on weekends, why not.
- Yeah, to actually stay engaged,
it seems like the name
of the game right now
and make sure they have
not just the academic,
the social engagement.
There's a question here,
this is actually a really
interesting question
and I'll broaden a little bit,
from YouTube Dave Hankin says,
Maria as a journalist
reporting on what's going on.
How do you feel about the misinformation
that's being spread about COVID
that's not necessarily
based on science or reality.
I have noticed that many
people are still in denial
about how serious it really
is and will continue to be.
And I'll broaden that question
even broader than COVID,
because it seems like the nature of media
has somewhat changed
over the last few decades
where it feels like it's more polarized
that people talk a lot about social media,
where you can kinda be in your own bubble
and only kinda hear what you wanna hear,
but it also feels like that has happened
even in the mainstream media
where you can watch the channels
that kind of feed your own viewpoint.
And I I've at least
read things in the media
that some of the incentives
even in the media houses
seem to be much more focused about
just purely engaging folks
and getting them hooked
versus giving the middle
of the road information
that may not necessarily
be what they wanna hear,
but it was actually closer to the truth.
How do you view that?
How do you view the evolution of media?
Are you seeing the same types of trends
and how do you think we can get to a world
where the media is playing that role
as at forth of state the institution
that kinda make sure that
we all have good information
and holds us accountable.
- Exactly, that's the role of
the media to seek the truth,
to denounce injustice, and corruption,
yet we are being threatened
and I think it also threatens democracy.
I mean, the media is
a pillar of democracy.
It's one of the pillars of
democracy, I should say.
I think it's very dangerous
when people don't believe the media.
And I understand what you're saying,
that the media is also divided,
and I think this is especially true
when you have these 24 hour news channels,
where they have 24 hours to
fill with all this information.
And also the trend that
started a few years ago
of not only journalists presenting shows
on these 24 hour show networks,
but also people that are not journalists,
people that are commentators,
people that are celebrities
or commentators,
they're not journalists.
So if you see someone
sitting behind a desk reading
with graphics on the side to you,
they look like any anchor, any
journalist that is reporting,
and it's not necessarily so,
they are doing commentary,
they're giving their opinion,
which is something that
a journalist doesn't do.
But if you watch ABC, CBS, and NBC News,
you're gonna see something very different.
I think that's where you get
most of your information,
but then you have half an hour only
and out of that half an hour,
it's really only 22 minutes of information
of the whole world because
of the commercial breaks.
So there's very little time for that.
So I think really people
need to do their research.
They need to, that's
their responsibility also
to be out there, to read as many
different sources as they can.
I know in my social
media, some people say,
Oh, I'm not gonna listen to the media,
I'm gonna listen to the experts.
And then you think, okay,
how are they gonna listen
to the experts if it's
not through the media?
Because the expert is
not gonna call you up
or send you an email and tell you,
this is the way things are.
What an expert is gonna do
is have a press conference
and make sure that the
media has the information
that they can relay to the people,
but to those affected.
But it does worry me, all
these conspiracy theories.
I mean, you see very
smart, intelligent people
believing some of these
conspiracy theories.
And I think it happens all the time.
We have 350 million, I
think people in the country
and we have 160 something
thousand that have died.
So if it doesn't, so the
great majority of people
are not affected by this.
They don't maybe not know someone
who has gotten sick or who has died,
so if it doesn't affect
you, you don't believe it,
but the moment it does,
the moment you have someone
in your family getting sick or dying,
that's what it takes for
you to take this seriously.
And I don't know that there's
anything we can do about that,
honestly, I wish there was a response.
I wish I could tell you,
this is the secret sauce.
This is the secret to
everybody paying attention
and listening and believing,
but that's not gonna happen.
People have these conspiracy theories
and they're gonna continue to have
these conspiracy theories, no
matter how much you tell them
that it's not true, but
it's very dangerous.
It's very, very dangerous.
- I mean to your point, something
like the crisis we're in,
it might be like that type of reality,
where at some point, those
opinions don't matter anymore
because at some point you do know folks.
I mean, just in our broader friend circle,
we know at least two people
who've actually passed away
from COVID and so I'm
guessing it is going to start
hitting a lot more folks.
I mean, related to that, have you seen,
like, when you talk to journalists,
people you've been
working with for decades,
do they feel like, yeah,
it's the good old days,
the good old days, we were all about
getting the information out there,
we weren't as concerned
with hooking people in.
We could, it wasn't just about soundbites
while now it's much shorter,
it's all about grabbing
attention, is there that trend?
I mean, that's obviously
I've asked that in a somewhat
biased way that's at least my perception
of how things have evolved.
- Well, in local news,
there's this saying that
"If it bleeds, it leads,"
which means that yeah, most media,
especially local media
always looks at something
that can grab you. Why?
Because people have the option of watching
different channels and you wanna grab them
from the beginning.
And that just goes to tell you
that people are very curious.
I don't wanna use the word morbid,
but usually those that
are more sensationalists
are the ones that have
the highest ratings,
people wanna watch.
And then they say, I don't
wanna know, I don't wanna know,
but I'm watching, I mean,
that happens all the time.
I do think that we wish we
were in the good old days
where we were reporting news
and not being questioned the
way that we are questioned now.
I'll tell you, one thing
that really affects people,
is the rhetoric against the
media, mainstream media,
coming from the highest
levels of government.
And I worked in Spanish
language media for decades,
like you mentioned in the beginning,
and we know we've covered a lot
of authoritarian governments
in Latin America.
And we know that
authoritarian governments,
what they do is one of
the first things they do
is try to silence the media.
They either kill them for
example, like in Khashoggi case
or they close down their business,
or they put them in jail.
They do anything that
they can to silence them.
I know recently I was in Nicaragua
and the way they tried to
silence the media there
is by kind of forcing them to go digital
because they put a special
tax on importing the products
to publish a newspaper, the
paper, the ink, the equipment,
and then another way of
doing it is calling them
the enemy of the people.
It's by discrediting journalists.
I mean, discrediting journalists,
I sometimes watch these 24 hour news
lets say I watch CNN quite a bit.
And I'm astonished when I
see some of these journalists
that I've been watching for years,
that I know are very good
journalists that I know are,
I shouldn't say objective
'cause objectivity doesn't exist anymore.
That are balanced, that give perspective
because that's what journalists
are supposed to be doing.
Constantly fact checking,
they're spending their whole time
on the air, fact checking
fact checking, fact checking,
fact checking and playing devil's advocate
against the nonbelievers.
And I think what's happening
now has pushed people
to be that way.
But I still think it's a noble profession.
Still very honored to be a journalist.
And I still do believe that our profession
is a profession that
we need to be proud of
and that we are there to serve the public.
We are there, we are the only
barrier between those in power
and those that they are trying to reach.
So if we weren't so important
they wouldn't be trying to silence us.
- Completely agree and as you point out,
now with social media where
anyone can publish anything
to have professionals who
are really going after facts,
I think couldn't be more important
than any other point in history.
Maria, whenever we're having
these interesting conversations,
the time goes way faster
than I ever expect.
I can talk to you for hours,
but I just really wanted
to thank you on my behalf
and whole the Khan Academy team
and all the viewers we
have for joining us.
I think we learned a lot and
I hope we can do this again.
- Thank you so much, Sal,
I really appreciate the opportunity,
sorry, sometimes I tend to talk too much
and go on and on and
on, but these are issues
that I'm passionate about,
I know that you are too,
and I thank you on behalf
of the Latino community
for also having this
(speaking in foreign language)
and making sure that students
of different nationalities
and the country and the world
have some kind of support
so that they can continue
so they can get ahead.
Education is one of the
most important things
that we can have.
And I think that everyone
is very well aware of that.
And in our case, in the Latino community,
immigrant families know that
education is the only way
their kids won't have to go
through what they went through
in order to get ahead.
So thank you so much for what you do.
- Thank you.
Well, everyone thanks so much
for joining today's live stream,
every time I think we're
like 10 minutes into it
and I realized I'm 31 minutes into it.
'Cause there's so much to talk about,
but I hopefully you enjoy the
conversation today with Maria,
as much as I did.
I look forward to more
of these conversations,
we're going to have a
Lester Holt on tomorrow,
and I think we'll actually
be able to continue
to some degree this
conversation about the media
and also I always find it interesting
because journalists report on
what's going on in the world.
But these are also very thoughtful folks
who are seeing aspects
of society in the world
that many of us don't get to see.
And so I think they really form
really interesting perspectives about
the context that we're in and
maybe ways to get out of them
or make them better.
But once again, thanks so much for joining
and I will see y'all tomorrow.